The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: What we're
going to talk about today
is a continuation of last time.
I want to review Newton's
method because I want to talk
to you about its accuracy.
So if you remember, the way
Newton's method works is this.
If you have a curve
and you want to know
whether it crosses the axis.
And you don't know
where this point
is, this point which I'll
call x here, what you do
is you take a guess.
Maybe you take a point x_0 here.
And then you go down to
this point on the graph,
and you draw the tangent line.
I'll draw these in a
couple of different colors
so that you can see the
difference between them.
So here's a tangent line.
It's coming out like that.
And that one is going
to get a little closer
to our target point.
But now the trick is,
and this is rather hard
to see because the scale
gets small incredibly fast,
is that if you go
right up from that,
and you do this same
trick over again.
That is, this is your
second guess, x_1, and now
you draw the second
tangent line.
Which is going to
come down this way.
That's really close.
You can see here
on the chalkboard,
it's practically the
same as the dot of x.
So that's the next guess.
Which is x_2.
And I want to analyze,
now, how close it gets.
And just describe
to you how it works.
So let me just remind
you of the formulas, too.
It's worth having
them in your head.
So the formula for
the next one is this.
And then the idea is just
to repeat this process.
Which has a fancy name,
in algorithms, which
is to iterate, if you like.
So we repeat the process.
And that means, for example,
we generate x_2 from x_1
by the same formula.
And we did this last time.
And, more generally, the (n+1)st
is generated from the nth
guess, by this formula here.
So what I'd like to do is just
draw the picture of one step
a little bit more closely.
So I want to blow up
the picture, which
is above me there.
That's a little too high.
Where are my erasers?
Got to get it a little
lower than that,
since I'm going to depict
everything above the line here.
So here's my curve coming down.
And suppose that x_1 is
here, so this is directly
above it is this point here.
And then as I drew
it, this green
tangent coming down like that.
It's a little bit closer,
and this was the place, x_2,
and then here was
x, our target, which
is where the curve crosses as
opposed to the straight tangent
line crossing.
So that's the picture that
I want you to keep in mind.
And now, we're just going to
do a very qualitative kind
of error analysis.
So here's our error analysis.
And we're starting out, the
distance between x_1 and x
is what we want to measure.
In other words, how close we
are to where we're heading.
And so I've called that, I'm
going to call that Error 1.
That's x - x1, in
absolute value.
And then, E_2 would be x
- x_2, in absolute value.
And so forth.
And, last time, when I was
estimating the size of this--
So E_n would be whatever it was.
Last time, remember, we
did it for a specific case.
So last time, I actually
wrote down the numbers.
And they were these
numbers, maybe
you could call them E_n,
which was the absolute value
of square root of 5 minus x_n.
These are the sizes that I
was writing down last time.
And I just want to talk about
in general what to expect.
That worked
amazingly well, and I
want to show you that that's
true pretty much in general.
So the first distance, again,
is E_1, is this distance here.
That's the E_1.
And then this shorter
distance, here,
this little bit, which I'll
mark maybe in green, is E_2.
So how much shorter
is E_1 than E_2?
Well, the idea is pretty simple.
It's that if this distance
and this vertical distance,
they are probably about the same
as the perpendicular distance.
And this is basically
the situation
of a curve touching
a tangent line.
Then the separation is
going to be quadratic.
And that's basically
what's going to happen.
So, in other words
the distance E_2
is going to be about the
square of the distance E_1.
And that's really the
only feature of this
that I want to point out.
So, approximately,
this is the situation
that we're going to get.
And so what that
means is, and maybe
thinking from last
time, what we had was
something roughly like this.
You have an E_0, you have
an E_1, you have an E_2,
you have an E_3, and so forth.
Maybe I'll write down E_4 here.
And last time, this
was about 10^(-1).
So the expectation
based on this rule
is that the next error's the
square of the previous one.
So that's 10^(-2).
The next one is the square
of the previous one.
So that's 10^(-4).
And the next one is the square
of that, that's 10^(-8).
And this one is 10^(-16).
So the thing that's impressive
about this list of numbers
is you can see that the
number of digits of accuracy
doubles at each stage.
Accuracy doubles at each step.
The number of digits of
accuracy doubles at each step.
So, very, very quickly
you get past the accuracy
of your calculator, as you
saw on your problem set.
And this thing
works beautifully.
So, let me just summarize by
saying that Newton's method
works very well.
By which I mean
this kind of rate.
And I want to be just
slightly specific.
If-- there are really two
conditions disguised in this,
that are going on.
One is that f' has to be,
not to big-- to be not small.
And f'' has to be not too big.
That's roughly speaking
what's going on.
I'll explain these
in just a second.
And x_0 starts nearby.
Nearby the target value x.
So that's really
what's going on here.
So let me just
illustrate to you.
So I'm not going to explain
this, except to say the reason
why this second
derivative gets involved
is that it's how
curved the curve is,
that how far away you get.
If the second
derivative were 0, that
would be the best possible case.
Then we would get
it on the nose.
If the second derivative
is not too big,
that means the quadratic
part is not too big.
So we don't get away very
far from the green line
to the curve itself.
The other thing to
say is, as I said,
that x_0 needs to start nearby.
So I'll explain
that by explaining
what maybe could go wrong.
So the ways the method can fail,
and one example which actually
would have happened in our
example from last time,
which was y = x^2 - 5, is
suppose we'd started x_0 over
here.
Then this thing would
have gone off to the left,
and we would have landed
on not the square root
of 5 but the other root.
So if it's too far away,
then we get the wrong root.
So that's an example,
explaining that the x_0 needs
to start near the root
that we're talking about.
Otherwise, the
method doesn't know
which root you're asking for.
It only knows where you started.
So it may go off
to the wrong place.
OK, it can't read your mind.
Yes, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, good question.
So the question was, what if the
first error is larger than 1.
Are you in trouble?
And the answer is,
absolutely, yes.
If you have quadratic
behavior, you can see.
If you have a
quadratic nearby, it's
pretty close to
the straight line.
But far away, a parabola is
miles from a straight line.
It's way, way, way far away.
So if you're foolish
enough to start over here,
you may have some
trouble making progress.
Actually, it isn't, when
I-- that little wiggle
there just meant
proportional to.
In fact, in the particular
case of a parabola,
it manages to get back.
It saves itself.
But there's no guarantee
of that sort of thing.
You really do want to
start reasonably close.
Yep.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What you have to
do is you have to watch out.
That is, it's hard to know what
assumptions to make about x_0.
You plug it into the machine
and you see what you get.
And either it works
or it doesn't.
You can tell that it's marching
toward a specific place,
and you can tell that that place
probably is a zero, usually.
But maybe it's not the
one you were looking for.
So in other words, you
have to use your head.
You run the program and
then you see what it does.
And if you're lucky-- the
problem is, if you have no idea
where the zero is, you may
just wander around forever.
As we'll see in a second.
So the next example
here is the following.
I said that f' has
to be not too small.
There's a real
catastrophe hiding just
inside this picture.
Which is the transition between
when you find the positive root
and when you find the
negative root here.
Which is, if you're
right down here.
If you were foolish
enough to get 0,
then what's going to
happen is your tangent line
is horizontal.
It doesn't even meet the axis.
So in the formula, you can
see that's a catastrophe.
Because there's an f'
in the denominator.
So that's 0.
That's undefined.
It's not surprising,
it's consistent
that the parallel line
doesn't meet the axis.
And you have no x_1.
So you had-- So if you
like, another point here
is that f' = 0 is a disaster.
A disaster for the method.
Because the next-- So
say, if f(x_0) = 0,
then x_1 is undefined.
And finally, there's one other
weird thing that can happen.
Which is, which I'll just draw
a picture of schematically.
Which you can get from a wiggle.
So this wiggle has three roots.
The way I've drawn it.
And it can be that you can
start over here with your x_0.
And draw your tangent line
and go over here to an x_1.
And then that tangent line will
take you right back to the x_0.
I didn't draw it quite right,
but that's about right.
So it goes over like this.
So let me draw the
two tangent lines, so
that you can see it properly.
Sorry, I messed it up.
So here are the
two tangent lines.
This guy and this guy.
And it just goes back and
forth. x_0 cycles to x_1,
and x_1 goes back to x_0.
We have a cycle.
And it never goes anywhere.
This is, the grass
is always greener.
It's over here, it
thinks, oh, I really
would prefer to go to
this zero and then it
thinks oh, I want to go back.
And it goes back and
forth, and back and forth.
Grass is always greener on
the other side of the fence.
Never, never gets anywhere.
So those are the sorts of
things that can go wrong
with Newton's method.
Nevertheless, it's fantastic.
It works very well, in
a lot of situations.
And solves basically any
equation that you can imagine,
numerically.
Next we're going to move on.
We're going to move
on to something
which is a little theoretical.
Which is the mean value theorem.
And that will allow
us in just a day or so
to launch into the
ideas of integration,
which is the whole second
half of the course.
So let's get started with that.
The mean value theorem will
henceforth be abbreviated MVT.
So I don't have
to write quite as
much every time I refer to it.
The mean value
theorem, colloquially,
says the following.
If you go from Boston to LA,
which I think a lot of Red Sox
fans are going to want to do
soon, so that's 3,000 miles.
In 6 hours, then
at some time you
are going at a certain speed.
The average of this speed.
Average, so, speed, which
in this case is what?
So we're going at
the average speed.
That's 3,000 miles
times 6 hours,
so that's 500 miles per hour.
Exactly.
So some time on your journey--
of course, some of the time
you're going more than
500 miles an hour,
sometimes you are going less.
And some time you must've
been going 500 miles an hour
exactly.
That's the mean value theorem.
The reason why it's
called mean value theorem
is that word mean is the
same as the word average.
So now I'm going to state it in
math symbols, the same theorem.
And it's a formula.
It says that the
difference quotient
- so this is the
distance traveled
divided by the time elapsed,
that's the average speed -
is equal to the infinitesimal
speed for some time in between.
So some c, which is in between
a and b-- I'm not quite done.
It's a real theorem,
it has hypotheses.
I've told you the
conclusion first,
but there are some
hypotheses, they're
straightforward hypotheses.
Provided f is
differentiable, that is,
it has a derivative in
the interval a < x < b.
And continuous in a <= x <= b.
There has to be a sense that
you can make out of the speed,
or the rate of change of f
at each intermediate point.
And in order for the values
at the ends to make sense,
it has to be continuous.
There has to be a link
between the values at the ends
and what's going on in between.
If it were discontinuous,
there would
be no relation between
the left and right values
and the rest of the function.
So here's the theorem,
conclusion and its hypothesis.
And it means what I said
more colloquially up above.
Now, I'm going to prove
this theorem immediately.
At least, give a geometric
intuitive argument,
which is not very different
from the one that's given
in a very systematic treatment.
So here's the proof of
the mean value theorem.
It's really just a picture.
So here's a place, and here's
another place on the graph.
And the graph is going
along like this, let's say.
And this line here
is the secant line.
So this is (a, f(a)) down here.
And this is (b, f(b)) up there.
And this segment is
the secant, its slope
is the slope that
we're aiming for.
The slope of that line is the
left-hand side of this formula
here.
So we need to find
something with that slope.
And what we need to find is a
tangent line with that slope,
because what's on
the right-hand side
is the slope of a tangent line.
So here's how we construct it.
We take a parallel
line, down here.
And then we just translate
it up, leaving it parallel,
we move it up.
Towards this one.
Until it touches.
And where it touches, at this
point of tangency, down there,
I've just found my value of c.
And you can see that if the
tangent line is parallel
to this line, that's exactly
the equation we want.
So this thing has slope f'(c).
And this other one has slope
equal to this complicated
expression, (f(b)
- f(a)) / (b - a).
That is almost the
end of the proof.
There's one problem.
So, again, we move
a parallel line up.
Move up the parallel
line until it touches.
There's a little subtlety here,
which I just want to emphasize.
Which is that that dotted
line keeps on going here.
But when we bring
it up, we're going
to ignore what's
happening outside of a.
And beyond b, alright?
So we're just going to
ignore the rest of the graph.
But there is one thing
that can go wrong.
So if it does not touch, then
the picture looks likes this.
Here are the same two points.
And the graph is all above.
And we brought up our thing.
And it went like that.
So we didn't construct
a tangent line.
If this happens.
So we're in trouble,
in that point.
In this situation, sorry.
But there's a trick, which
is a straightforward trick.
Then bring the tangent
lines down from the top.
So parallel lines,
sorry, not tangent lines.
Parallel lines.
From above.
So, that's the whole story.
That's how we cook up this point
c, with the right properties.
I want to point out just
one more theoretical thing.
And then the rest, we're going
to be drawing conclusions.
So there's one more
theoretical remark
about the proof, which
is something that is
fairly important to understand.
When you understand a
proof, you should always
be thinking about why the
hypotheses are necessary.
Where do I use the hypothesis.
And I want to give you an
example the proof doesn't
work to show you that the
hypothesis is an important one.
So the example is the following.
I'll just take a
function which is
two straight lines like this.
And if you try to perform
this trick with these things,
then it's going to come up
and it's going to touch here.
But the problem is that
the tangent line is not
defined here.
There are lots of
tangents, and there's
no derivative at this point.
So the derivative
doesn't exist here.
So this is the claim that one
bad point ruins the proof.
We need f' to exist at all--
so, f'(x) to exist at all x
in between.
Can't get away even with
one defective point.
Now it's time to draw
some consequences.
And the main
consequence is going
to have to do with
applications to graphing.
But we'll see tomorrow and
for the rest of the course
that this is even
more significant.
It's significant to all
the rest of calculus.
I'm going to list three
consequences which you're
quite familiar with already.
So, the first one is if f' is
positive, then f is increasing.
And the second one is if f' is
negative, then f is decreasing.
And the last one seems
like the simplest.
But even this one alone
is the key to everything.
If f' = 0, then f is constant.
These are three consequences,
now, of the mean value theorem.
And let me show you
how they're proved.
I just told you that they
were true, maybe, a while ago.
And certainly I
mentioned the first two.
The last one was so simple
that we maybe just swept it
under the rug.
You did use it on a
problem set, once or twice.
But it turns out that this
actually requires proof,
and we're going to give
the proof right now.
The way that the proof goes
is simply to write down,
to rewrite star.
Rewrite our formula.
Which says that (f(b) -
f(a)) / (b - a) = f'(c).
And you see I've written
it from left to right here
to say that the right-hand
side information
about the derivative
is going to be
giving the information
about the function.
That's the way I'm
going to read it.
In order to express
this, though, I'm
going to just rewrite it
a couple of times here.
So here's f(a), multiplying
through by the denominator.
And now I'm going to write
it in another customary form
for the mean value theorem.
Which is f(b) =
f(a) + f'(c) (b-a).
So here's another version.
I should probably have
put this one in the box
to begin with anyway.
And, just changing it
around algebraically,
it's this fact here.
They're the same thing.
And now with the formula
written in this form,
I claim that I can
check these three facts.
Let's start with the first one.
I'm going to set things
up always so that a < b.
And that's the setup
of the theorem.
And so that means that
b - a is positive.
Which means that this factor
over here is a positive number.
If f' is positive,
which is what happens
in the first case, that's the
assumption that we're making,
then this is a positive number.
And so f(b) > f(a).
Which means that
it's increasing.
It goes up as the value goes up.
Similarly, if f'(c) is negative,
then this is a positive times
a negative number,
this is negative.
f(b) < f(a).
So it goes the other way.
Maybe I'll write this way.
And finally, if f'(c)
= 0, then f(b) = f(a).
Which if you apply it
to all possible ends,
means if you can do it for
every interval, which you can,
then that means
that f is constant.
It never gets to change values.
Well you might have believed
these facts already.
But I just want to emphasize
to you that this turns out
to be the one key link
between infinitesimals,
between limits and these
actual differences.
Before, we were saying that
the difference quotient
was approximately equal
to the derivative.
Now we're saying that it's
exactly equal to a derivative.
Although we don't know
exactly which point to use.
It's some point in between.
I'm going to be deducing some
other consequences in a second,
but let me stop for
second to make sure
that everybody's on board.
Especially since I've
finished the blackboards here.
Before we-- everybody happy?
One question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm just going to
repeat your question first.
I'm a little bit
confused, you said,
about what guarantees that
there's a point of tangency.
That's what you said.
So do you want to
elaborate, or do you
want to want to stop
with what you just said?
What is it that confuses you?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So I'm not claiming
that there's only one point.
This could wiggle a lot
of times and it maybe
touches at ten places.
In other words, it's OK with me
if it touches more than once.
Then I just have more,
the more the merrier.
In other words, I don't
want there necessarily only
to be one.
It could come down like this.
And touch a second time.
Is that what was concerning you?
So in mathematics,
when we claim that this
is true for some point,
we don't necessarily
mean that it doesn't
work for others.
In fact, if the
function is constant,
this is 0 and in fact this
equation is true for every c.
That satisfies your question?
The fact that this point exists
actually is a touchy point.
I just convinced
you of it visually.
It's a geometric issue, whether
you're allowed to do this.
Indeed, it has to do
with the existence
of tangent lines
and more analysis
than we can do in this class.
Yeah.
Another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Pardon me.
PROFESSOR: The
question is, what's
the difference between this
and the linear approximation.
And I think, let me see
if I can describe that.
I'll leave the
theorem on the board.
I'm going to get rid of
the colloquial version
of the theorem.
And I'll try to describe to
you the difference between this
and the linear approximation.
I was planning to
do that in a while,
but we'll do it right now since
that's what you're asking.
That's fine.
So here's the situation.
The linear approximation,
so let's say comparison
with linear approximation.
They're very closely related.
The linear approximation says
the change in f over the change
in x, that's the left-hand
side of this thing,
is approximately f'(a).
For b near a, and
b - a = delta x.
This statement, which
is in the box, which
is sitting right up
there, is the statement
that this change in f is
actually equal to something.
Not approximately equal to it.
It's equal to f' of some c.
And the problem here is that
we don't know exactly which c.
This is for some c.
Between a and b.
Right, so.
That's the difference
between the two.
And let me elaborate
a little bit.
If you're trying to understand
what (f(b) - f(a)) / (b -
a) is, the mean value theorem
is telling you for sure that
it's equal to this f'(c).
So that means it's less
than or equal to the largest
possible value on the-- largest
value you can get, for sure.
And this is on the
whole interval.
And I'm going to
include the ends,
because when you take a max it's
sometimes achieved at the ends.
And similarly, because it's
f'(c), it's definitely bigger
than the min on this
same interval here.
This is all you can say based
on the mean value theorem.
All you know is this.
And colloquially,
what that means
is that the average speed
is between the maximum
and the minimum.
Not very surprising.
The mean value
theorem is supposed
to be very intuitively obvious.
It's saying the average
speed is trapped
between the maximum speed
and the minimum speed.
For sure, that's
something, that's
why-- incidentally this
wasn't really proved when
Newton and Leibniz were around.
But, let's write this
so that you can read it.
Average speed is between
the max and the min.
But nobody had any trouble,
they didn't disbelieve it
because it's a
very natural thing.
Now if, for example, I take any
kind of linear approximation,
say, for instance, e^x
is approximately 1 + x.
Then I'm making the guess-- no,
I don't want to say this yet.
That's not going to explain
it to you well enough.
What we're saying, so this
is the mean value here.
This is what the mean
value theorem says.
And here's the
linear approximation.
The linear approximation is
saying that the average speed
is approximately the
initial speed, or possibly
the final speed.
So if a is the left endpoint,
then it's the initial speed.
If it happens to be the right
endpoint, if the value of x
is to the left then
it's the final speed.
So those are the-- so you can
see it's approximately right.
Because the speed, when
you're on a short interval,
shouldn't be varying very much.
The max and the min should
be pretty close together.
So that's why the linear
approximation is reasonable.
And this is telling
you absolutely,
it's no less than the min
and no more than the max.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The little kink?
PROFESSOR: If you
approach from the top.
So if it's still under here
I can show you it again.
Oh yeah, it's still there.
Good.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, the one
with the wiggle on top?
Yeah, this one you can't.
Because there's nothing
to touch and it also
fails from the bottom because
there's this bad point.
From the top, it could work.
It can certainly work both ways.
So, for example.
See if you're a
machine, you maybe
don't have a way of doing this.
But if you're a human being
you can spot all the places.
There are a bunch of spots
where the slope is right.
And it's perfectly OK.
All of them work.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's not
that the c is the same.
It's just we've now found
one, two, three, four,
five c's for which it works.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] PROFESSOR:
If you're asked to find a c,
so first of all that's
kind of a phony question.
There are some questions
on your problem set
which ask you to find a c.
That actually is struggling
to get you to understand what
the statement of the
mean value theorem is,
but you should not pay a lot of
attention to those questions.
They're not very impressive.
But, of course, you would have
to find all the-- if it asked
you to find one, you find one.
If you can find some more, fine.
You can pick whichever
one you want.
Mean value theorem
just doesn't care.
The mean value
theorem doesn't care
because actually, the mean
value theorem is never
used except to-- in real life,
except in this context here.
You can never nail
down which c it
is, so the only
thing you can say
is that you're going slower
than the maximum speed
and faster than
the minimum speed.
Sorry, say that again?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: If you're
asked for a specific c,
you have to find a specific c.
And it has to be in the range.
In between, it
has to be in here.
So now I want to tell you about
another kind of application,
which is really just
a consequence of what
I've described here.
I should emphasize, by
the way, this, probably,
should be doing this.
I guess we've never
used this color here.
It's popular.
This is pink.
So this one is so good.
So since we're going to do this.
So the reason why the
exclamation points
are temporary, this is
such an obvious fact.
But this is the way
that you're going
to want to use the
mean value theorem,
and this is the only way
you need to understand
the mean value theorem.
On your test, or ever
in your whole life.
So this is the way
it will be used.
As I will make very clear
when we review for the exam.
In practice what
happens is you even
forget about the mean value
theorem, and what you remember
is these three properties here.
Which are themselves
consequences
of the mean value theorem.
So these are the ones that
I want to illustrate now.
In my next discussion here.
I'm just going to talk
about inequalities.
Inequalities are relationships
between functions.
And I'm going to prove a couple
of them using the properties
over there, the
properties that functions
with positive derivatives
are increasing.
Here's an example.
e^x > 1 + x, where x > 0.
The proof is the following.
I consider-- So here's a proof.
I consider the function f(x),
which is the difference.
e^x - (1+x).
I observe that it starts at f(0)
equal to, well, that's e^0 -
(1+0), which is 0.
And, it keeps on going.
f'(x) is e^x, if I differentiate
here, the 1 goes away.
I get minus 1.
That's the derivative
of the function.
And this function, because e^x
> 1 for x positive, is positive.
As x gets bigger and bigger,
this rate of increase
is positive.
And therefore, three
dots, that's therefore,
f(x) is bigger than its
starting place, for x > 0.
If it's increasing, then
that's-- in particular,
it's increasing starting from 0.
So this is true.
Now, all I have to do is read
what this inequality says.
And what it says is that
e^x, just plug in for f(x),
which is right here, minus (1+x)
is greater than the starting
value, which was 0.
Now, I put the thing that's
negative on the other side.
So that's the same
thing as e^x > 1 + x.
That's a typical inequality.
And now, we'll use
this principle again.
Oh gee, I erased
the wrong thing.
I erased the statement
and not the proof.
Well, hide the proof.
The next thing I want to prove
to you is that e^x > 1 + x +
x^2 / 2.
So, how do I do that?
I introduce a function g(x),
which is e^x minus this.
And now, I'm just going to
do exactly the same thing
I did before.
Which is, I get started
with g(0), which is 1 - 1.
Which is 0.
And g'(x) is e^x minus - now,
look at what happens when I
differentiate this.
The 1 goes away.
The x gives me a 1, and the
x^2 / 2 gives me a plus x.
And this one is positive for
x > 0, because of step 1.
Because of the previous
one that I did.
So this one is increasing.
g is increasing.
Which says that g(x) > g(0).
And if you just read that
off, it's exactly the same
as our inequality here.
e^x > 1 + x + x^2 / 2.
Now, you can keep on going
with this essentially forever.
And let me just write
down what you get.
You get e^x is greater
than 1 plus x plus x^2 / 2,
the next one turns
out to be x^3 / (3*2).
x^4 / (4*3*2).
And you can do
whatever you want.
You can do others.
And this is like the
tortoise and the hare.
This is the tortoise, and this
is the hare, it's always ahead.
But eventually, if you go
infinitely far, it catches up.
So this turns out to be exactly
equal to e^x in the limit.
And we'll talk about that
maybe at the end of the course.